well there's been reaction across Europe
and the United States we're going to
have two correspondents following
developments Mike Hannah is in
Washington DC first we're going to go to
Sonia Gallego in London a lot of
European countries allies of Ukraine
giving them cash and also Military
Support what's been the reaction across
European capitals
and as you can imagine all
all are
a situation the ongoing situation series
of events that have been occurring in
Russia uh first of all the British
governments which are convened an
emergency committee is to discuss the
ongoing situation uh has happened
already on Saturday the British prime
minister Rishi sunak did say that he is
going to be speaking with other allies
and reiterated that all parties in the
conflict in Russia should do their
utmost to avoid harm to civilians
looking at the defense side of things
the British Ministry of Defense in
irregular intelligence updated stated
that according to its own information
the Loyalty of the Russian security
forces and especially that of the
Russian national guard is going to be
key to how the crisis plays out and it
represents the most significant
challenge to the Russian state in recent
times it also
stated that with very limited evidence
of fighting between Wagner and the
Russian Security Forces they some have
likely remained passive and acquiescing
to Wagner that's again according to the
British Ministry of Defense elsewhere
across the European Union the president
of the European Council charm Michelle
the European Council of course the
organization that unites the leaders of
the European Union country stated that
they are also looking at this situation
very closely and also that they're on
and also pledging their unwavering
support for Ukraine and the president of
volodimir zelensky uh similar Echoes of
this occurring across the the Europe the
European Union countries as well Italy
traditionally kind of taking a softer
stance on Russia regarding sanctions as
interestingly also said that while it is
monitoring the events and it's showing
that it's assault on Ukraine is causing
instability within Russia meanwhile the
German foreign minister has met with
counterparts of the G7 to discuss the
issue more closely they're also
monitoring it as well as our other
countries especially that are
geographically closer to the Ukrainian
border of course they have more of a
security issue there but all countries
have within the European Union avoided
uh or certainly urged citizens not to
travel to that area but all in all
they've just literally passed on
Wednesday another set of sanctions which
is affecting how other nations trade
with the European Union to make sure
that they aren't Russia isn't having any
other issues with Goods that are maybe
passing on to them so all in all but
very very close monitoring of the
situation of the events and of course
the hours and the days to come will be
uh very important for how the European
Union reacts to those events Sonia thank
you very much much for breaking down
that European reaction to Forest San
Diego in London I'm going to go to Mike
Hannah in the American Capital Mike the
impression I get from talking to Sonia
talking to to Jonah and even in Ukraine
is that there is very much a kind of
wait and see policy at the moment
um how is the US reacting to all of this
well very much that weight and see
policy but very very closely monitoring
as the situation there transpires the
Secretary of State Anthony blinken has
held phone calls with all his G7
counterparts all the U.S allies
including the UK Japan Germany France so
this is a sign of exactly how seriously
the U.S is taking the situation the fact
that the secretary of state is in
telephone contact with all the Allies
coordinating a response to the ongoing
events uh within Russia and on its
borders now within Congress there has
been overwhelming support for Ukraine
and its ongoing struggle with Russia for
a long period of time some Congress
members tweeting out that the Ukraine
should seize the opportunity to make
gains in the battlefield however within
the Biden Administration there's a
degree of caution about the say are
deeply concerned about military splits
that in Russia the impact that that
would have on the U.S and and indeed on
the entire Globe so that is one of the
reasons why the whole situation is being
watched very very quickly because of
that type of ripple effect that could
happen across the world with any
dismembering of Central Power Within
Russia or any
non-political Handover or seizure of
power now that may be a long way down
the road but certainly that is a concern
and that is as well something that the
U.S military planners are looking at
what would be the consequences of
splintering within Russia all of this a
massive cause for concern uh the U.S
President Joe Biden was due to travel to
Camp David within a few hours it's not
certain whether he's still going to
carry on with that meeting but obviously
the U.S both political and Military are
closely monitoring the situation Mike
thank you very much indeed That's my
kind of bringing us up to date and
Washington D.C